hello Internet sa viewers Welcome to our
Channel where we delve into the digital
world to bring you insights and tips for
a smarter online experience today we are
exploring a crucial topic the best web
browsers for privacy so let's dive in
and find out which browsers are your
best allies in protecting your online
privacy in an era where data breaches
and privacy invasions are increasingly
common choosing a web browser that
respects and protects your privacy is
more important than
today's web browsers including the
widely used Google Chrome often serve as
tools for collecting data on behalf of
advertising companies what this means
for you is that these companies use your
browsing data to generate profits by
enabling targeted advertising it's
important to know that switching to
private or incognito mode doesn't fully
protect your privacy your IP address is
still out in the open allowing various
third parties to track your online
activities even considering legal
options may not be enough to safeguard
your online privacy in this context
before moving to the list just a quick
info for you if you want to upskill
yourself master cyber security skills
and land your dream job or grow your
career then you must explore simply
learns cohort of various cyber Security
Programs simply learn offers various
certification and post-graduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like MIT it
kpur EC Council and many more through
our courses you will gain knowledge and
work ready expertise in skills like
Advanced hacking Concepts Network packet
analysis ethical hacking network
security and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in top tier product and security
companies and academicians from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transition into a cyber security role as
a fresher or move on to higher paying
job and profile if you're passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comment and description box to
find a cyber security program that fits
your experience and areas of Interest so
let's get started most modern browsers
offer a range of privacy features these
include like ad blockers tracker
blockers and Incognito modes but not all
browsers are created equal let's see how
they really stack up when it comes to
keeping your online activities private
let's delve into an analysis of top web
browser focusing on two critical aspects
number one security we will explore the
effectiveness of these browsers in
safeguarding you against cyber threats
such as hacking system weaknesses and
malicious online activities number two
privacy our discussion will include the
extent of personal data collection by
the browser the entities this
information is shared with and the
measures in place to ensure your online
privacy so let's start with the number
one browser Brave the most secure and
private browser for both desktop and
mobile Brave widely recognized as 2023
is most secure and private browser for
desktop and mobile stand out for its
straightforward and robust privacy
features here's a concise summary for
the key attributes number one it is
based on chromium Brave developed by ex
Mozilla employee Brandon Ike is built on
the open-source chromium platform but
with enhanced privacy settings number
two default privacy features it comes
with pre-installed ad blockers and
browser fingerprinting protection
including fingerprint randomization this
makes it an excellent choice for users
seeking privacy without the need for
complex customizations number three
additional security tools the browser
includes a script blocker blocks
thirdparty storage and provides easy
access to the to network for anonymous
browsing number four userfriendly
interface known for its speed and ease
of use Brave ensures privacy without any
required adjustments from the users it's
also compatible with Chrome extensions
adding to its versatility number fifth
Innovative features Brave continually
innovates featuring its own ad program
for noninvasive advertising a private
search engine named Brave search a
cookie consent blocker Brave news for
RSS feeds and a built-in cryptocurrency
wallet Brave wallet and in March 2023
Brave further enhanced its offerings by
integrating an AI powered summarizer
into Brave search despite some
criticisms about its ad program Braves
approach provides a secure funding model
ensuring its future and continuous
innovation you can find out details
about Brave's privacy features on the
website now coming to number two Firefox
Firefox renowned for its robust privacy
and security features stands as an
excellent choice for a secure web
browsing experience the browser known
for its speed and lightness becomes even
more secure when customized for privacy
initially Firefox may not offer the best
privacy settings but with the right
modifications which are detailed in a
specific guide it can be significantly
enhanced users are advised to disable
the Telemetry feature which collects
technical data and may run studies in
the browser the privacy and security
settings in Firefox offer various levels
of privacy customization including
standard strict and custom options
additionally Firefox supports numerous
extensions that further boost privacy
and security Now talking about key
highlights of Firefox include number one
open source code independently audited
for added trust next regular updates
from an active development team and
coming to next wide ranging privacy
features and customization choices and
the next is total cookie production to
guard against tracking cookies and Fire
Fox view for quick access to recently
visited sites and it has built an ad
blocker to enhance browsing experience
and it has support for a variety of
browser extensions Manual disablement of
telemetry and tracking for improved
privacy and the next is additional
modifications available for heightened
privacy and security for those needing
to use older add-ons in compatible with
the latest Firefox version the Firefox
extended support release that is ESR is
a viable alternative for Android users
seeking maximum privacy Firefox focus is
a recommended option this was all about
the Firefox now coming to the third
option that is to browser the T browser
a modified Firefox variant operates on
the tour Network and emphasizes privacy
particularly against browser
fingerprinting however its Reliance on
the tour Network which involves three
hope traffic routing results in slower
download speeds and potential website
compatibility issues due to script
blocking the toone network faces
challenges like risky exit noes High
latency frequent blocking by websites
and debates over its US Government
funding sparking concerns about its
Integrity an alternative approach
involves using the to browser with the
to network deactivated making it
function similarly to other secure
browsers this setup coupled with a VPN
offers faster encrypted internal access
while concealing your IP address while
the toour browser has both Advocates and
critics a new collaboration between
mulard and the tour project presents an
Innovative option and a question is
advised when altering the tour browser
settings as this can beon its inherent
privacy and security protections now
coming to the number fourth Libra wolf a
privacy focused Firefox alternative
Libra wolf is gaining traction as a
previously Centric browser evolving from
Firefox it prioritizes user privacy
security and Freedom the browser
enhances protection against tracking and
fingerprinting with added security
features and its key attributes are
number one blocking Telemetry and data
collection number two built-in privacy
enhancements like UB block origin number
three regular fast updates number four
open source nature and lib wolf stands
out for its commitment to user Freedom
rejecting DRM and other restricted
features available for various desktop
OS that is Windows Mac OS Linux openbsd
it's a solid choice for those valuing
privacy and security however it requires
manual updates minor inconvenience
balanced by frequent easy to install
updates always aligned with the latest
Firefox version lib wolves updates
follow closely behind Firefox releases
ensuring current features and security
now coming to number fifth mulard br
browser a privacy collaboration between
mulard and Tor the mulard browser a
result on the collaborative efforts of
mulard VPN and the to project offers a
unique approach to online privacy this
browser integrates the Privacy enhancing
features of the to browser such as
blocking trackers and preventing
fingerprinting without the need to
connect to the to network instead it is
optimized for use with a high quality
VPN while mulard recommends pairing
their browser with their VPN service
it's not a requirement this setup with
other vpns is suggested as a potentially
more effective privacy solution than
using the to network alone and now
talking about the key highlights of the
browser number one collaboration between
bouvard VPN and the toour project number
two incorporates privacy features of the
to browser without using the to network
number three designed for use with a
quality VPN not limited to mad's own
service number four offers an
alternative privacy Sol solution to
using the tone Network directly so which
browser takes the crown for the best
privacy remember your choice depends on
your specific needs and preferences
thanks for watching for more Tech
insights and tips don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and ring the bell
icon for notifications till then get
certified get ahead staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and up Skilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success
click the link in the description to
know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn ner up and get certified
click
here